[Music]
[Applause]
so far this be smiling I've had one
spliff out of this our other big spliff
is remaining one knock me out
well that's it that's it there it's not
much but that's means you write about
probably get about four five pound but
you're only gonna need a part of that
wall time but that's a knock you are
equal didn't sleep one night and someone
offered you a bit of joy I'm not going
to sleep one night the next day if it
was a good idea
you owe me man that's how these
addictions sir I get a couple of drunks
are my three for drugs out of it and
that doesn't mean that those darling
meet about six in the wine everybody my
stomach hurt sometimes gonna be sick
depends a bust off I've been smoking
so on some came to twelve second really
I can wake up with there anything which
I get passed along with a joy - yes I'll
put that in a giant I've already eaten
O'Connor got also any bit what out does
it that starts distant drums it stops
everything so it's just over says it's
over
people who see anything else up there
but didn't like Haiti on the streets you
don't feel my feet you don't see enough
you don't feel my feet
that's why you know what yeah and that's
why people take it yeah they put blocks
everything Connie Street our everything
a player we face it
coming up low like a stone leaf over
your weight your lap you're aware but
you know in control so it takes all
means you stop each study car birth
may they forego I don't W it is
forbidden to that move no means won't
you shut your eyes feel the light you
feel comfortable okay you should prob
stoned I think is it's honorable the way
it's made but every two terrible I think
people just very judgmental no one goes
how about I won't know about belly Nicky
Damania
I walk through the mind don't even once
I know what being pain or when I smoke
them comfort
time flies absolutely flies
[Music]
it's very hectic and which I've just
been speaking to the guys then the
reason why it's so hectic is because
they're not closed door and then well
you know somebody comes we're crisis led
service somebody comes to the front door
and the need help because you can't we
have a drop-in Tuesday Friday suit till
4:00 but you can't say somebody have a
crisis it's a little confused and we'll
help you a lot worse because now you're
not getting sealed pockets so you don't
know what's in them some spice that you
buy on Deansgate use difference what
unites buying Piccadilly Gardens it's
now kind of every man for himself
it can be tampered with a lot more
because it's now being sold in the snap
bugs and it's turned sort of the
community of people against each other
now because one may not smoke by us
anymore but they'll sell it and the
getting people's quite on beg for it and
they're actually making people I'll give
you some spies what you need to go out
and beg for it and then give me the
money that you get from begging so it's
a hundred million times worse than it
was before the bum so why why do they
need to get themselves into such a state
that they're on a different planet and
not being able to do their day to day
life if you can get to that root cause
of that problem and the reason why they
feel that way then we can suckle it
criminalizing it that makes absolutely
no difference whatsoever and we are paid
double for a packet of it if we can get
it in a bucket rather and what like I've
shown you last night in a buck off the
street I'd rather to get it in a pocket
when it says on a bucket it says what's
in it exactly what's in it on the back
of it you know what I first watched
devoting their first small space in
strange ways there that's what I first
smoked by he self sweaty one on the
floors and me and sitch it was they've
got a jump on the iron part jeremiad
revival this is very new role this is
where they legalized shop was in the
first place I go and see we're walk if
we watch on us house and usually have
them covers out we would get off at
Spice I was playing package from Radwell
and it was like you can get you could
get a gram you could get a grant for for
a fiver
you could get a bounce the 15-pound it's
a lot cheaper and I had on the packets
what what was in it yeah you could get
black chronic green chronic plot where
coverings when he was getting it in the
packets with the shop behind goes right
if you're getting it in the pocket from
there you knew what was in it it said
everything that was in it and I said not
for human consumption and believe me I
don't know what's in it nobody knows
what's in spice right now
out the other day I suppose a giant and
when I come round I've got two
paramedics with me and it I didn't even
know and it seems to me come on get in
the ambulance to see what you're on
about I thought thought needs an
ambulance to see you do you out cold on
the floor on a roll
don't always think about it so and
that's because they've got all this in
space but despise what's about now
because it's a because you're you just
don't know what's in it don't get around
what spice have got a smaller smoke was
much succeed that way I don't feel it i
bought thought I bought feel like maybe
every died last year we don't feel like
the moons
I thought remember none of it I thought
what I remember none of it that's why if
they like us by war or war that's why
I'm covering up on him and I will cover
it on its on the moon so moon as well
because I can't sit there watching
I'm not like my brothers and sisters I
can't sit down and watch it back I can't
do that I sort of put myself on the
street I'll stay on the street and pee
out air rather than watching my wingback
[Music]
people smoke it because it's cheap and
easy when this small spice it makes you
forget about your problems like if you
smoke that you're not going to think
where am i staying tonight
where am I gonna have a wash where I'm
gonna get food from you don't think
nothing your weight caught the other
drag spiced at your head are you
thinking that we're going to get my next
back where I'm gonna get minutes back
kids are just getting origami or like
chopped up marshmallow plants soaking it
in acetone nail varnish remover okay
liquid cleaner for your alloy is soaking
it a Kleenex got chemical salt into it
it's smoking it's dangerous it's more
more stronger now than it ever was
before
so it's more of a situation more
dangerous now than it was back then do
you know what I mean
the way that spices is generally
manufactured is that the chemical is
purchased usually through the dark we're
perform and it's imported illegally and
then what will happen is is it it's a
powder which is then dissolved up in an
appropriate solvent something like could
be something like what nail varnish
remover or something like that
it's then mixed with in an inert plant
material and then are dried and then
separated into that the bug the small
bags that we see on the street are we
smoking upwards of fifty eight gram a
day to try and kill myself to get rid of
the pain of losing my sister none and so
many friends ended up it was no way to
describe other than drug-induced
psychosis I was seeing things that
weren't really there a police officers
approached me one morning I've lashed
out because I didn't see a police
officer I've just seen a shape coming at
me and I've ended up in prison for six
months for a BH who's after my release I
start smoking spice again it was about
three weeks after my release
there smoked a large spliff of spice I
ended up vomiting uncontrollably ended
up rupturing my stomach to the point
where I was vomiting blood Arthur up a
pint and a half of my own blood and
ended up in a 14 day coma you can say to
a hospital absolutely destroyed me I
ruined my life with it I ended up
homeless ended up walking away from my
friends my job my home everything or
because it spice it's like I'd never go
near again and I'd warn any one of my
friends to stay away from it because it
kills people and it ruined your life
you're typically say you know I know it
sounds tough but when you smoke it on
the streets it makes you feel wild and
you feel like you've got one blanket
around you that is exactly our heroin
user would talk about using heroin
feeling warm feeling in clothes or the
gander say it's the only thing that gets
mr. sleep in China gets to sleep in a
car park you know you've worried about
being attacked feeling really vulnerable
if a smoke adjoint of spice you know it
gets mr. sleep so it seems tough this
ability to condense time whether it's to
make you know three four or five hours
pass make a long period of time feels
shorter so again you speak to homeless
people and they'll say and I've been on
the streets for two years it feels like
two months horrific it's you know we've
had people that we know of sort of
anecdotally that the SWAT from heroin on
sir spies because it's cheaper and then
they found it's harlots heal fast and
they stick out of heroin someone else
and seven minutes of that is walking off
the street so we see it's very it's easy
you know and if you see people in a
certain way you'd approach them in less
than where they get it from or if you're
around the city sense a long enough
it'll probably ask you if you want a
version I could set use right now to the
central picket of the gardens and just
stand there with one spotlight is and
your watch people come into missing you
want to bias bias that's the worst thing
that's how horrible it is in Manchester
no splash is too easy to get all of man
you can stand in one spot like this
swimmer said you want some Finch what we
draw its price you want crack you want
here we know it's flooded the town was
horrible do you know what I mean
everyone was person he's I'm citizen
auspices
Manchester's foot for aspire spices
foots it when the police made it illegal
that's when they made it worse
he kept it legal and driving everybody
off it properly they wouldn't be after
that drowned years now they wouldn't be
after people right now because obviously
these be a police have just snapped
offshore shops down people still
addicted to it it's that Butler they
killing each other for it you know
someone's gotten in someone's pocket
because he's got in someone's pocket
they've then said your corn pickin on
sort with me so when he was going for
spice to work no [__] spice it was a
stick job we just take you under canal
to kill him they bought him the one she
father killed him now
nice you killed off through spice that's
this that's the second one animate sir I
know it's been killed off his pious
wandering but burn in his tent it was
it's fierce pious and the rest of you
didn't already passed it in for a spice
that kid was only nineteen nineteen and
got killed and it sent three spice just
because he had a few spliff and they
didn't atmosphere probably kids day what
I display any other spliff they killed
that poor kid for a spy
[Laughter]
[Music]
so postman we've been seeing spice in
this sort of form here so it's a very
nondescript green plant material now if
you actually bought the cannabinoid on
the market and then manufacture that
you'd probably be spending a couple of
pounds to actually import the
cannabinoids a gram of that that would
produce five hundred bags of half a gram
in weight and you'd probably get a
markup of about two thousand five
hundred pounds
it's sort of got a catch weight through
that although the drug dealers now like
people used to deal cocaine heroin crack
all the big-time drug dealers now have
sort of moved away from that they still
do that on the sidelines but now they've
got spices and main avenue because it's
such a moneymaker it's quite basic and
quite easy to do you can go online now
and you can search you know how to make
spice to make synthetic cannabinoids and
it's been a step-by-step process of
instructions about how you would
actually do that so if you think how
many homeless people in Manchester City
Center say has a rough number say five
thousand there's a rough number five
thousand people get ten or a pound a day
five thousand times ten or twenty
there's nearly 50 bucks 50 grand that's
a lot of money as I was a lot of income
to begin just from people who are
begging of others on the streets and
never mind people who have got jobs you
pay a way to get a wage and pay for that
so it's such stupidly easy money that
people they just think the stupid to
turn away from it
people aren't running to him to get off
Lords only me it's hard to actually
realize I want to stop and I need help
we can't tell them to stop smoking it
they've got a want to change herself you
know all these deaf involved but you
still take that chance 50-50 chance
every drugs a 50-50 chance if you're
gonna live or die basically is one drug
could kill somebody don't what I mean it
is it's like a it is kind of like a
heroin rattle in the way because you
start used to make starts getting cramps
up it starts sweating when you're
freezing you know your calls you wrapped
up in a big coal but you start sweating
this right in the sweating you start
shaking physically shaking like that
it'd be sick I have blood coming out of
it and everywhere you know what I mean I
know people that have been on the
streets for 34 years they've been heavy
heroin and crack users for those for
those three or four years and even they
won't go anywhere near spice
I mean I've physically seen it with my
own eyes like people to woken up
thinking they're gonna have the sweats
and the runs from heroin withdrawal and
really the shaking from a spice was
wrong and they haven't even noticed that
the other gun gear for like four weeks
have just been smoking spice
[Music]
don't despair when it used to be in the
pocket they never knocked you out like
up here oh yeah well not like that like
like now you could say to you pause of
it oh I thought I bought from heroin
since back but I haven't I mean not
still having an era when I bit a spice a
bit and a crack of it so instead of
getting rid of respite the smack of it
and getting a spice a bit I've ended up
coming damning all free so everyone and
I do go for free weights as Papago spice
a bugger smart and a piece of crap and
then that's breakfast that's my
breakfast at all I won't eat and not
thinking I love them now when I've done
that that's people to go good for
everything known about that so it's all
about that was nasty as possible to the
soul
it's fast to me it's a whole new class
right you get your class BC a I think
spices are never class above a anything
man-made with chemicals now of the
Carlin a new form of spice like
crystallized MDMA we saying its
crystallized spice it's the new man-made
chemical drug can kill you instantly
instantly my one that would have adapted
can injure the concentrations have
potencies have been around two to seven
percent
prior to the ban post ban we saw a
massive spike specifically in Manchester
and that was associated with a
significant rise in potency by about ten
times the the normal dose that we were
looking at between about seventeen to
twenty percent and that was that was
directly linked to about fifty three
emergency call-outs that were received
that when we came originally was to say
compared to cannabis you could buy a
gram for ten pound and you could get 30
to 40 Giants from one gram so people
talk about just need in a tiny pin hurt
like the coolant of a grain of rice and
put that in a joint then people would
talk about in a matter of mum's the
tolerance builds up to such a degree
that there then smoke in five six seven
eight grams a day and it's quite common
when we've been doing the research to
see somebody put a half gram pack into
one joint so the girl from going first
is 240 joints out of one gram to just
getting one or two joints out of a pack
raven a gruff bar point fires about two
hours I get a couple of joints are most
three four joints out of it
and that doesn't mean that that
Dharamsala 6:00 in the morning
never never I mean I'm old school I
remember that it's in the days of pills
and MDMA and all those kind of things
it's I'd call it an epidemic I've never
seen anything like it just because
you're in a [__] place and you might
know where else to go nothing else to do
there's not mean you have to sit there
and smoke spice and obliterate yourself
I reckon if you put any one of the
politicians are sitting in houses of
parliament now put them on the streets
go yeah is a split for spice I'm going
to come back to you in a month's time
see how bad you are guarantee that was
out there were no [__] shoes I mean a
foil blanket begging for spice that's
what it does to everyone it just rips
your every humanity everything you are
as a person if anything is just a
thousand times more dangerous because
when it was still legal it was being
made by companies that are regulated
there was a certain amount of regulation
in the actual product itself certain
chemicals weren't added they were
measured properly but now people are
buying the formulas offline making it at
home so people are making their own
mixtures up and editing the recipes in
different ways and that's why people are
dying so quickly now
so you don't know where the products
come from don't know how powerful it is
don't know what's been added so what's
been taken away from it basically it's a
game of roulette if you go and buy spice
from a dealer in the city now you're
playing a game of roulette because one
drag could kill you one drag will drop
you dead because it could have been
laced
[Music]
they could kill you for a fiver just for
five pound by the spice they could take
your life and they're not bothered
because they've made the money off it
now it's your family that deals with
everything after your spy shoes to know
what I mean
used to stop them in spices just killing
people if the government carried on sell
it in the shop you won't have half of
the problems you have now our promises
it's a billions upon industry when it
was legal so what's it going to be like
no it's illegal didn't what I mean it's
bad game well
now whether it's legal class a BRC is
not really going to have any impact on
people's kind of decision make and
Rabbids whether to use it or not and I
think the focus is always to be you know
targeting the dealers and in terms of
the users it's about trying to engage
them in treatment what we need to look
at is reduced in the answer and most
people that you speak to they'll say
they were first introduced to spice in
the prison system so we need to do more
work in the prison system to stop people
using it because the prison system is
basically turning our spice users into
the community so if you criminalize use
as you put them into prison then you
know that's just self-perpetuating this
kind of cycle place is all smoking crack
whole collar it's working they're three
five seven minutes would be like what
the cartoons like what [__] these
gate and you get it you get it feeling
lost Chinatown you get it go ahead
Manchester City Center is full of spice
a little - don't know
no this was walking this is probably
Oh
[Music]
hey okay No
you